what I think of what bridge goes British
girls what are you talking about
[Laughter]
[Music]
he's a kid like he can't be black
nothing
it can't be black bad that you can't be
he can't beat the suey can't beat the
supernatural powers I love Tom Hollander
actor but I think I think that's a no
contest actually probably Andy Serkis
Andy is an incredibly nice guy an
extremely talented actor
yeah I'll say he's probably just like
its character Daniel Daniel partly at
least like his character baby I don't
think I can say okay I could say I think
the Black Panther film is important to
the world mainly because you know we've
never seen anything like this before
we've never I don't think we see African
culture expressed on this stage in this
way the way women are art showing this
movie it just feels good like all of it
feels good so it's important for all
those reasons I think it's extremely
important I think it's a it's it's
spot-on it's the perfect time for having
Marvel get behind this project and
really like champion this I you know
this idea this message this film we get
a lot more people to be I think more
open-minded to something that they
didn't they wouldn't maybe normally be
able to sit down and watch yeah so I
think moving forward you'll see more
studios and more projects you know be a
little bit more diverse and I yeah we'll
see what happens like ten years from now
you know a mom would say probably suit I
wore for the MTV Movie Awards it was
like a orange red plaid - I thought it
was nice she didn't think so she didn't
tell me before I went out the house she
told me like years later which I think
was a little [ __ ] up when she told me
like after the fact like she watched I
hear like
go out into the world when she thought
it was like horrible but anyway she
don't hurt my foot whatever would I
think what bridge goes British girls
what are you talking about I think you
trying to get me I think he's trying to
give me in trouble
I've always loved British women but but
right now you gonna give me a trouble
back home you just put it like that